foreign
[Music]
much discussion about this lately what
names you would give to aliens
um you're right I have we haven't no I
don't I don't mean given names like on
their birth certificate oh okay I mean
if if they're from a planet they would
be called the what right that makes
sense so we on Earth to aliens wear what
well that's weird because
there's two things because you know I
like a lot of sci-fi yeah now in the
corny sci-fi yeah they call us
earthlings earthlings
but in the serious sci-fi they call us
terens terens oh oh all right yeah all
right so if you're serious no no no no
in the really serious sci-fi they call
us dinner
okay
or snack all right well let's tease that
out so so so
the planets are named for Roman gods
okay so Mercury Venus Mars Jupiter
Saturn Uranus Neptune Pluto okay oop did
I say Pluto
didn't the other grass Tysons just
reinstate Pluto as a planet we'll fix
that in
post-production so
um well then so does Earth have a name
does the moon have a name does the Sun
have a name we do and if you stay with
the Roman tradition Earth would be
Terror
the moon would be Luna
okay and the sun would be soul s-o-l
okay okay and if you look at old Maps
you know and old uh uh illustrations of
the solar system I mean from centuries
ago people would put that in because if
it's in Latin and the book is written in
Latin Earth is Terror and Earth Luna and
soul so I would understand that the more
Latin literate erudite aliens would
cause Terrence Greetings oh where's this
guy think he is which would be most
people's responses
you could call Miss Terry well I have I
have degrees in Latin how about you
who is Terry I don't understand why he
keeps calling us that okay so now if
you're from the Moon
then you go back to the lunar you'd be a
lunatic
that's pretty cool I want to live on the
moon then
up for grabs like you would you want to
call them lunarians you could do that
that's no lunatics it's way better
that's way better it's lunatics all
right
um and so Mercury would be mercurians
okay this is what's called the genitive
form of the word uh Mercurial would be
the adjective uh if so if you're Venus
venusian okay all right that's pretty
well known there right and any before we
knew that Venus was 900 degrees
Fahrenheit uh Venus being named after
Venus the god of love and beauty any
portrayal of Venus
with aliens there they were all
beautiful women
at all times
that that makes perfect sense beautiful
women that will uh burn you to a
Christmas time Venus Venus so before we
knew it would burn into a Christmas all
right so so let's go hit Mars and of
course that's the famous Martian we got
that right and beyond that you have
Jupiter and so Jupiter would be uh you
can think jupitarians I was going to say
jupitarian you can simplify that and
call them jovians
by jove yes by jove is by Jupiter
yeah okay
did not know this one didn't know that
one okay and Saturn could be saturnians
okay and whatever uh
Uranus first okay all right so now all
right are you uranians no you're an
a-hole
oh your anus
oh
guys oh
no
that's a sci-fi movie I want to see if
if all the residents of Uranus Uranus
were a-holes
us
so I I have to check on that one uh your
ran uranians I have to think of Iranians
the Iranians awareness uranians okay and
Neptunes would be neptunians neptunians
that sounds great yeah and uh Pluto I'd
say I totally say plutonians plutonians
yeah I mean why not yeah yeah actually
um there's an episode of Rick and Morty
where they go to Pluto and by the way uh
they uh bring Jerry who's a character
who is a bumbling idiot in the in the
series they bring him to Pluto to
um
Jerry is Morty's father right Jerry yes
his father and so they bring him to
Pluto to praise him for making Pluto a
planet oh I saw that episode yeah I saw
that that was weird that one was weird
celebrate him for making Pluto a planet
you know anyway all right so
plutonians but but so here's the here's
we gotta correct one of these though
okay okay uh if you were from Venus
you're not really venusian okay we we
had to clean that one up
okay the correct
genitive term to be a Venus is to be
venereal
okay
[Music]
the medical doctors got to the word
before the astrophysicist did okay and
so they find this disease peculiar to
love making and they name and they like
name and stuff into the mythological
Dungeons and so they dig up whatever it
would be they find the you know the
planet the Goddess that is responsible
for lovemaking and love beauty and all
that goes with it and they say let us
call these diseases of Venus
venereal diseases
and I'm sure she was just like thanks a
lot now Russia had more Landers on Venus
than we ever had we focused on Mars
Russian Landing all their Landers are
called veneris
that the again the roots of an aerial
Venera just look up Venera those are
Landers on Venus sent by Russia back
even during the Cold War they were
explorers too okay yeah so the problem
is if if people if people from Venus
come say hi I'm venereal how are you
that's awkward right hi I'm venerio how
are you I'm clean that's how I am I'm
clean it was nice to meet you wouldn't
want to be you see you
so uh as far as other aliens I mean they
might I would like to keeping with the
woke movement I would want to call them
what they want to be called themselves
okay rather than come up with some name
for them I'm all about that period right
right it's like Columbus coming to the
new world I'm looking for India you must
be Indians right this is just and we
kept calling them in the info like four
centuries yeah I was gonna say that's
where the real problem was okay it's one
thing for one guy to be like hey these
guys are Indians yeah because to adopt
it as formal cultural uh
right right right now if I say what
shall we call you and they say oh you
will call us Master it's like no
yeah that ain't happening yeah all right
there I do have a line about what I'm
going to call you let me tell you
something if that were the case we like
just damn the brother can't catch a
break
yeah call me master boss right right all
right yeah yeah yeah man just got
through there just got through the South
yeah and the America fought a war this
again but
[Laughter]
um so it's the way we're naming
exoplanets unless there's one we have
good data on and people like uh being a
little more creative the way it works is
there's the name of the star
and this star has the letter A
associated with it
as the first object discovered in the
system in that system okay the next
object typically a planet would be a b
trap is B okay there you go so that
would have been the first planets
discovered in that Trappist system that
uh Trappist is a uh is a it's a very
fertile star system it has multiple
planets that took a while to extract out
of the data but they're there so there's
a b c d e f so uh that's just what we
call them in our catalogs but that's not
a fun thing if we find aliens there
you're not going to call it Trappist be
Beyonds you know right so we have to do
some more thinking about that
I like that that's that's a fun game to
give planets names and so and systems
where we know that there are planets
that exist then you have a chance of
calling them calling the aliens of that
planet something that would but I got
one more before we go okay okay so we're
looking for life on Jupiter's moon
Europa okay so I'm thinking if we find
life there we would have to call them
Europeans Oh I thought you were going to
say white people
[Music]
laughs
Chuck is still not making progress in
his race therapy sessions I know I need
help I need help
it's
um you know so the Europa you'll be
Europeans Europeans I don't see why not
not europians right no Europeans
Europeans that's kind of there it is and
uh Saturn's largest moon Titan uh though
we call them Titans yo that's that's bad
that's the badass ones that's who I want
to be from yeah yeah so anyhow it's fun
to think about what you would call the
aliens once we have a name for the for
the object and just the one I wanted to
correct for the record was venusians is
what we all accept but it's not
authentic it's it's venereal you're
authentically venereal if you're from
Venus and that is today's explainer
sorry Venus we got the test back
so sorry
what's up
all right there's been another star talk
explainer on something you probably
didn't know you could care about Chuck
always good to have you always what Neil
deGrasse Tyson as always keep looking up
foreign
[Music]